yes this is an excellent segue into this
other story we were initially going to
leave with this one then the juicy
smoothie stuff broke but check this out
reuters says facebook temporarily allows
posts on ukraine war calling for
violence against invading russians or
putin's death what that to me is
absolutely amazing they say
meadow platforms will allow facebook and
instagram users in some countries to
call for violence against russian and
russian soldiers russians and russian
soldiers civilians and soldiers holy
moly in the context of the ukraine
invasion what does that mean what does
that mean does that mean you can be like
i just plain don't like the invasion and
then say just kill civilians or
something like every russian should pay
yes right until until when you know the
thing that i don't understand about all
of these sanctions and even just these
ideas that you've got to take it out on
russians and i even saw this video that
was circulating of this group in canada
that was uh painting they were they were
um vandalizing a russian community
center you know with and they were
painting all over blue and yellow and
it's just
okay if if we in the west continue to
assert and believe that vladimir putin
is a dictator and that he isn't that
they don't live in a democracy then why
would we take anything out on the people
what what purpose is that because you
should only do that if you think the
people are then going to turn around and
pressure their government or you're
punishing them for voting that
government in like they were a democracy
and look at the bad choice you people
made but if you don't believe it's a
democracy then what are you doing well
so the reason i think this was an
excellent segue from the previous uh
segment ian was talking about how there
could be an executive decree like okay
now this thing is is not allowed anymore
in this instance we're seeing what
happens happens when we end up in
corporatocracy where our social
discussions our society is being ruled
by technocrats in silicon valley who
change the rules on a whim mark
zuckerberg apparently mark zuckerberg
apparently they'll say you can't do
these things they're against the rule
and then when they want to enact massive
societal change they'll come out and be
like you are now allowed peasants do as
we say yeah
that's creepy yeah well i see calling
for violence against invading russians
that's not what it is no no no russians
and russian soldiers in the context of
ukraine invasion
what that means
that way it depends on what it means so
we'll have to see the exact policy they
say as a result of the russian invasion
of ukraine we have temporarily made
allowances for some for forms of
political expression that would normally
violate our rules like violent speech
such as quote death to russian invaders
we still won't allow credible calls for
violence against russian civilians okay
that's an important objection except
who's a russian invader
right the russian military what about a
guy who's like invalid vladivostok is
like chilling in a boat
so now like the guy making steel like in
in the middle of the country that is
getting shipped to make the tanks you
know he's part of the war machine now
even though he's a civilian but they're
pretty clear that they don't want to
target civilians
but again the the definition of a
civilian is where it gets really muddy
and that's what's going on even with the
war you know when they're talking about
oh these civilians are being killed in
ukraine and it's like well okay but what
do you classify who do you classify as a
civilian when they're conscripting
everybody giving them a gun telling them
to fight so if every male 18 to 60 years
old is given a weapon and told to go
fight now his civilization is no longer
but i think they might be counting them
as civilians for sure i agree but you'd
what you'd have to call them militia
you'd have to say like you know russians
kill 12 militia they're not doing that
because it's all a big propaganda
machine sure this this this stuff scares
me because
it sounds some people would argue it's
reasonable oh but we're talking about
war and violence and i'm like i don't
care you know we have two problems here
one i don't think you should be calling
for the death of people i think you can
say we're being invaded i will defend
myself and defend my country that i
understand but to be like i am calling
for the death of this group or whatever
the other issue is that
the the rules of our society and what
ideas are allowed are being dictated by
technocrats who are unelected now that's
a scary prospect you want to claim
vladimir putin as bad as a dictator i'll
be like sure what about our society
being dominated by facebook and google
how much industry is digital now
how many people have jobs that are based
on youtube or facebook or or twitter or
whatever and these companies but my
private platforms they can just
eliminate you from your entire job gone
in an instant because they decided it
but do you think they're the ones
deciding or do you think the politicians
are pressuring them
because then it really does become a
first amendment issue when if they're
making policy decisions based on the
pressure they're getting from
politicians because they're afraid of
regulation
i think it's both
yeah that was my thought too
both it just seems like from a platform
perspective you'd want no regulation
whatsoever you'd want just people to say
whatever and you wouldn't care because
that brings more people to your platform
yeah so
my biggest question is who would be
wanting to make it so that you can say
this about russia well well hold on yeah
we have an update we have we have new
the temporary policy changes on calls to
violence calls for violence to russian
soldiers applies to armenia azerbaijan
estonia georgia hungary latvia lithuania
poland romania russia silva russia
slovakia and ukraine according to an
email that means if you're a russian
citizen in russia you can be calling for
the death of your own military if you
are polish nato country or lithuania or
latvia or estonia you can call for death
it's very interesting very weird yeah
zuckerberg for sure wants ukraine to win
the war i mean he's bought into the
propaganda and he's an ideologue yeah i
don't think it's zuckerberg personally
he makes all the decisions did we have
the administration actively pressuring
social media companies to remove vaccine
misinformation we know that the united
states government is above doing this
kind of thing however i will say to your
point asking about uh whether zuckerberg
could have any motivation to avoid
regulation it's interesting because
facebook has actually been pushing for
certain regulations surrounding speech
codes online i think it might actually
be advantageous for them in some ways
depending upon what the legislation is
because then people aren't angry with
them as a comp for as a company when
they ban people and they won't be likely
to go to competitors they'll just see it
as a large overarching thing and then
those regulations that facebook loves
the place in its terms of service become
policy for the entire country so small
people who might compete with facebook
by having a more free speech platform
won't be able to do so
or they're just trying to get into the
china market that's possible as well
absolutely i actually think that's
really what's going on with google
twitter and facebook as they're trying
to get into the china market and they
were banned back in 2011 china said you
can't come into our country because
you're not willing to censor and their
response was we're an american company
we have american values we don't censor
and now that's obviously changed
censorship
it's here man it's coming yeah they're
more than [ __ ] up go announce it we'll
get into that a little bit
they just destroyed
themselves what i use
why would i use duckduckgo ever again
after this what's the better search
engine i don't know brave brave has
their own rave oh it does
somewhat someone tweeted that
but uh you know i wanna we'll stay a
little bit focused on the on on this
because there's another bit of news
related to this we talked about with
imagine noise facebook previously
allowed you to praise
uh one nazi group the azov battalion so
if you were if you were actively
praising nazis on facebook so long it
was the ukrainian soldiers that was
allowed that's crazy you can't praise
the swat they don't they're afraid of
the swastika but not nazism just the
swastikas although they have a swastika
it's like that diagonal one yeah and
it's like half a swastika as a battalion
yeah yeah yeah but facebook is like okay
this time it's fine that's so crazy
that's crazy the enemy of my enemy is my
friend all of these people putting the
ukrainian flags in their profiles who
just last month were like we got to
fight the fascists are now like well
these fascists
is crazy when nawaz was here he pointed
out that what's happening is people from
around the world are going to join azov
to fight and then they're becoming
radicalized and learning how to fight is
this with a terrorist group and then
they're going to go home
radicalized and create their own little
pockets of azov or nazism or whatever
that's his fear he's i guess he's seen
it before i mean it's not uncommon it's
an interesting isis too well we already
saw this sort of you know this is just
another proxy war that we're having with
russia right now in ukraine and it
actually mimics a lot what we did
in um you know this is the new
afghanistan get out of one war to start
another you know just got to replace the
afghanistan war and this is very similar
to what happened in afghanistan in the
80s because what the u.s government was
doing the carter administration started
and then it continued on with reagan was
was funding the mujahideen yep and that
they were fighting the russians because
the russians were with the with the at
the time the afghan government brought
in the russian military to fight and the
mujahideen was fighting against the
russians we armed the mujahideen we
trained them we didn't go in we didn't
fight the russians specifically we let
them do it and they were battling their
own country they were trying to get
their own country back from the soviets
right freedom funds and we boasted that
we had given russia their own vietnam
yeah by
entangling them yes because it was well
understood that the vietnam war was
horrible for america both in terms of
foreign policy and domestic policy right
because this country started to fall
apart and there was a lot of cultural
turmoil as a result and so we said if we
could give one of those to russia it
would sure help pace in the collapse of
the ussr keep in mind when you when
terrorists work for your com country
they're called freedom fighters that's
yeah well and we saw what happened to
the mujahideen al-qaeda evolves from
them and we go over there and fight them
what are you guys saying that the azov
had been like killing russians for tens
of thousands of russians over the last
five or eight years or something wasn't
like 14 000. well 14 000 people have
been killed in the dunba in the civil
war between the separatists and the
dunbas region and
um and the government because you know
there's an area of ukraine that has been
controlled by the separatists since 2014
and during this civil war conflict which
you know we call in the west we say that
they are russian-backed
um freedom you know russian-backed
separatists really they're ukrainians
fighting ukrainians in a civil war and
there's been 14 000 fatalities there but
a lot of them have been this battalion
and these sort of um
very you know not i mean really there's
no way to say it other i mean these are
not like far right these are actual
nazis um and they have been doing a lot
of that doing a lot of this battle but
you know hillary clinton even came out
like
two a week and a half ago i think that
she was giggling about well you saw how
it worked out in afghanistan for the
soviets when you know you saw how well
that happened because they ultimately
had to back out of yeah and then what
happened
that was in the 80s in the mountains now
we're talking about flat land in 2020s
but it's still a similar thing we're
arming a group we're giving him a bunch
of weapons this group ideologically is
is very you know it is they're not
aligned with really democratic values
western values fundamentally but we're
still saying oh but you're our friends
now because you're fighting our enemy
and that's exactly what happened in the
mujahideen in afghanistan and that did
not turn out well ultimately we ended up
in a war in afghanistan that we could
not win and we've been in the middle
east this entire time and so to your
point with we're you know then they're
recruiting all of these fighters that
are coming in from every other european
country and they're very far-right
radical people that are going to fight
alongside these battalions and yeah
we're arming them helping them out and
who knows what that will reel into 20
years from now i mean how long did it
take for the mujahideen to turn into
al qaeda and then you know all and
taliban it could very well happen that
ukraine is split the east goes to the
russia the west goes to azov and we've
got a nazi country basically that's
that's i think exactly what's going to
happen i don't know if it'll go to them
specifically yeah yeah i think the west
will go to nato eu right but they'll
have the those the battalion in there i
mean they'll be part of well i don't i
don't i don't know you know i think when
you look at isis it's i'll just say this
my opinion the west clearly wanted isis
to function because it was destabilizing
syria the u.s wanted syria they wanted
us the assad regime to fall so that the
u.s could get their pipeline up to
displace the russian gas monopoly so
isis is there and it's like oh no oh we
can't stop i saw g's and then trump
comes in he's like flatten them wipes
isis out that's actually a problem for
the west
for you know nato the us and cia because
then what's going to cause syria to fall
yeah azov they need another boogeyman so
if the us gets so right now
the us
has uh uh as of if russia takes ukraine
then all of a sudden you might see this
rampant destructive nazi battalion and
the us will be like oh this is so oh
it's so bad and somehow they'll end up
with u.s trucks and vehicles and weapons
yes absolutely oh well oh we have to
fight that rebel group that we funded a
while ago that's so crazy that we have
to fight the nazis
you ever see the isis the video of the
isis guys in the truck and it's got like
jim's plumbing from detroit michigan on
the side of it or something i think
that truck there were pictures from
syria that came out that had a kid
wearing one of my high school's gym
shirts on it because someone had donated
their gym shirts and other clothing to
some other organization it ended up in
their hands thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you